ich möchte jetzt über ein irrsinn
sprechen der mich seit monaten aufregt
seit der einführung und wir bekommen
aber als film nach reaktionen ganz viele
nachrichten darüber und ich finde es
sehr wichtig dass wir darüber heute
sprechen werden und das ist die
einrichtung zunge impfpflicht über
diesen irrsinn sprechen wir jetzt ich
finde es wirklich eine frechheit das
muss ich wirklich sagen wir hatten am
montag und das freut mich da gab es
keinen kroner toten binnen 24 stunden
eine großartige nachricht aber darauf
muss die politik doch jetzt endlich
reagieren wie kann es denn sein dass wir
immer noch die einrichtungs bezogen
impfpflicht haben wie kann es sein dass
pfleger wenn sie nicht geimpft sind
daran verzweifeln nur darauf warten wann
werden sie jetzt eingezogen also wann
wird das gesundheitsamt wann werden sie
dorthin gemeldet und dann dürfen sie
nicht mehr arbeiten ich finde das muss
aufhören und ich möchte es wirklich noch
mal ganz klar machen es kann nicht wahr
sein dass ich beispielsweise als
journalistin nicht überprüft werde aber
dass pflegekräfte also die menschen die
wir so sehr brauchen die in der kroner
krise härter gearbeitet haben als ich
als journalist dass die jetzt weiterhin
eine impfpflicht haben ich finde es eine
bodenlose frechheit der politik und
deswegen finde ich dass es aufhört muss
doch als letzten punkt möchte ich
ergänzen die politik macht übrigens mit
der einrichtungs beziehungen impfpflicht
nicht nur die pflege kaputt oder noch
härter als sie schon ist sondern sie
drängt die pflegekräfte in die
querdenker und auch das muss endlich
aufhören weil die ems entscheidung ist
eine persönliche entscheidung die jeder
für sich alleine treffen muss und auch
das jetzt bin ich gespannt wie die runde
darüber denkt und ich gebe direkt mal an
sie herr fuchs
zustimmen werden das gefühl trügt sie
nicht weil es gibt schon eine besondere
verantwortung von pflegekräften gilt
auch für gesundheitspersonal in
krankenhäusern nämlich für ihre
schutzbefohlenen für die patienten für
die alten in der pflegestation und wir
hatten zum teil extreme
infektionsquellen in pflegeheimen in
altenheimen und deshalb ist das eher
doppelter schutz für
die menschen die dort versorgt werden
aber auch für das pflegepersonal ja und
wenn pflegepersonal reihenweise ausfällt
weil sie sich gegenseitig anstecken dann
trägt das auch nur wenn sie reihenweise
ausfallen weil sie nicht geimpft sind
noch nicht mehr dürfen
ja ich meine es gibt ja in vielen
ländern frankreich zum beispiel sagen
diese impfpflicht seien im
gesundheitssystem klopp wir haben sogar
auf die
bildungseinrichtung sagen mit mit
übertragen der große frage mich an ich
frage mich immer also warum
verweigern dass die leute ja ist das
eine frage von aufklärungen von beratung
aber was kann man tun um sie zu
überzeugen aber zunächst ist das nicht
bevormundung sondern es ist
ja und in solchen einrichtungen in denen
die infektionsgefahr besonders groß ist
habe ich auch verständnis für eine
pflicht was ist mit den nebenwirkungen
ich habe in meiner zeit mitgebracht und
zwar gibt es also das
paul-ehrlich-institut
0,2 prozent entschieden an durch die
krone impfung aber laut einer impfstudie
von professor dr harald mathis geht man
von 0,8 prozent aus von der charité und
das sind bei rund 179 millionen
impfdosen sind das ca 1,5 millionen
schwere nebenwirkung schwere teil wäre
das heißt im schädel schwere
nebenwirkung heißen stein die wirkung
des tees können dauerhafte seien zum
beispiel häufig ist das vorhandensein zu
viele autoantikörper blutplasma der
betroffen machen sie jetzt aber gerade
gegen das impfen ich mache keine
propaganda dagegen lassen sie mich
ausreden ich würde aber auch keine dafür
machen weil ich bin weder eine die dafür
werben will oder nicht ist es für jeden
eine medizinische entscheidung nur ärzte
können dafür werben oder dagegen was
sagen aber ich weiß nicht ich bin ja
keine ärztin aber was ich eigentlich
sagen weil es bei dieser einrichtung
bezogenen impfpflicht
dürfen wir es den menschen aufzeigen
wenn es nebenwirkungen gibt und es gibt
ja impfschäden in deutschland auch von
der krone aber ich meine jungs schäden
sind doch auch statistisch viel geringer
hast du die zeit die schäden durch
corona und zwar gerade bei hochaltrigen
leuten und bei kranken menschen also mit
denen wir es zu tun haben in
pflegeheimen und in krankenhäusern da
kann man doch nicht drum herum reden ist
doch eine abwägung von risiken niemand
sagt ich meine ich bin kein mediziner
würden keine biologe aber niemand sagt
impfen ist vollkommen harmlos und
risikofrei es geht um eine abwägung
zwischen möglicher schäden durch impfen
unter schäden durch nicht impfen
aber wir reden jetzt von
oder ich sagte 32 im
pflegebereich alle kläger unter 3 na ja
aber ich sag es zumindest nicht im
rentenalter so und dass die frage kann
man sich schon stellen ich persönlich
bin bei dem thema ein bisschen
zwiegespalten im trier wieder bin ja es
ist immer alles ja nein man muss auch
ein bisschen irgendwo in der mitte
prinzipiell bin ich gegen die
impfpflicht prinzipiell bin ich auch
eher gegen einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht ich verstehe die argumente
aber und das ist mir wichtig es ist
nicht immer jeder irgendwie fundamental
opposition der sagt ich möchte mich
nicht impfen lassen und es gibt auch
leute die irgendwie durch impfschäden in
der familie in der vergangenheit oder
dergleichen irgend wie vor geprägt sind
und manche leute auch da haben wir das
thema wie bei frau schwarzer sind
einfach ängstlicher und wollen gewisse
risiken nicht eingehen jetzt muss man
abwägen ist mir die korona infektion ist
die für mich kritischer oder ist das
impfschaden risiko für mich höher ich
kann persönlich sagen ich bin mit corona
erkrankt gewesen für mich ist es eine
laufende nase gewesen und das war es
dann aber auch drei mal geimpft weiß
nicht wie sonst ausgefallen sie habe
nach dem muster so auch wir werden ja
alles noch 100 mal gepostet
ohne software auch sagen es ist da eben
auch nicht wenn man gegen einen
einjährigen wäre natürlich heike
lebendig gespann wäre wenn sozusagen
glaubensbekenntnisse ausgetauscht
moralische kriterien angewendet dann
finde ich das ganz toll und eine debatte
und dann können sich hier das war ich
würde mal einen
wettbewerbsgedanken ins rennen werfen
ich glaube wenn der tag kommt an dem die
einrichtungen und die es da geht keine
pflege mehr haben weil so viele sagen
wenn es dann impfpflicht gibt dann ist
es kein arbeitsplatz für mich ist die so
schnell weg die impfpflicht wie wir gar
nicht sozusagen schauen können das heißt
ich plädiere dafür selbst diese hoch
moralische hoch heikle und mit guten
gründen beim diskutierte frage den markt
entscheiden zu lassen das wird das
regulativ sein denn dann ist ihr
argument der abwägung noch mal anders
dann würde ich sozusagen als staaten
überlegen ist jetzt nicht die abwägung
möglichst viele pfleger zu haben um für
die menschen in not da zu sein und ist
dann nicht das geringere in der abwägung
die impfpflicht reaktionären haben sie
denn schon mal gefragt wie viele
pflegekräfte gekündigt haben oder wie
viele krankenschwestern weil ihnen das
infektionsrisiko zu haben oder weil die
arbeitsbedingungen so miserabel sind und
die bezahlung ein wichtiges thema der
arbeit gesehen dass das stimmt ist für
mich natürlich aber ich glaube dass er
sozusagen
das kennzeichen für den arbeitsplatz du
musst geimpft sein sonst kannst du hier
nicht arbeiten wird auch im wettbewerb
unter druck kommen und dann ist die
debatte ganz neu aber nach den gleichen
prinzipien das wäre mir wichtig auch
dann nach einer abwägung was jetzt das
sinnvolleres ich habe das gefühl dann
kann man auch zu der auffassung gelangen
sinnvoller künstlerleben einrichtungs
bezogen wieder wegzunehmen also ich
würde gerne über mein thema reden wenn
ich mir wenig da war aber ich habe das
rennen schon davon über mein team
andreas interessanter ist also ich
bin begeistert aber eine sache dass du
nach wie vor temperatur aus bei diesem
thema ich mich dieses thema zu behalten
möchte das wort kronen hat mindestens
bis zum herz nicht mehr hören und zwar
wirklich wahnsinnig verein druckt dass
du diesen zungenbrecher einrichtungs
bezogen im flieger dazu unfallfrei
aussprechen kann sondern vielleicht noch
ein boot und da kommt nicht mehr dran
ein einziges wort und dann in alexander
selbst ein team angeführt nur noch zwei
sätze dazu sagen ich glaube die pflicht
sowohl die einrichtungs bezogene als
auch die allgemeine werden durch die
durchseuchung die wir gerade erleben
irgendwann hinfällig werden also dadurch
dass wir es dann alle irgendwann hatten
ist dann die geschichte auch hoffentlich
vorbei und das braucht gar keine
ernstlichen gegeben sie sind können auf
einen milderen verlauf